CBS News chief Washington correspondent
Face the Nation to anchor John Dickerson
joins us now from Washington John good
morning morning Charlie what do you make
of this campaign to eliminate all leaks
at the White House it is they what kind
of errand is it well you know like might
much in life the tighter the tighter you
squeeze on something the less you may
have the problem with leak
investigations in all past white houses
is that it clamps down on people inside
of the White House it creates an
atmosphere of a little bit of Terror you
you get rid of people who are who are
leaking it makes everybody kind of look
over their shoulder and it's often that
leaks are the sign of a White House
that's not operating in a healthy way
why do people leak now I'm talking here
about harmless leaks not national
security leaks which we'll talk about
later but harmless leaks are the results
of a process that doesn't work where
people feel like they're not being heard
where their opinions are being discarded
where things are happening to their
colleagues that irritate them or that
seem like they're not fair or disloyal
and that is hard to fix by clamping down
White House's are healthy when people
are all working for a common purpose but
if they see that it's all about
self-preservation or that people can
make end runs around the process then
they leak and so it's really harder to
fix then by just firing people or
threatening to fire ban John shouldn't
we be clear leaks about personnel policy
in this game of Thrones style stuff
that's going on inside the White House
is not illegal no it's not illegal it's
not illegal at all it's happens to white
houses and going you know both
Republicans and Democrats Jimmy Carter
had a terrible problem with leaks and
and his chief of staff threatened to do
exactly what Anthony scaramouche E is
doing and it doesn't really work also
for this other crucial reason White
House needs White House's need leaks
they need relationships with reporters
to float things out there without making
them official to take care of stories
that may look bad but need explanation
off the record they need a conduit of
information with with reporters that
those pathways then are used by people
who are disgruntled by a process that
doesn't work to leak information that
again as you pointed out is not illegal
but it's just inconvenient but here's
another import
I've been reporting on healthcare
Republicans working on health care right
now are talking not about leaks from the
White House they're talking about things
that have come out of the president's
own mouth distracting his agenda what he
said to the Boy Scouts what he's doing
to Jeff Sessions with which Republicans
on the hill are scratching their head
about why he's trying to lead him to the
end of the gangplank there those are
things that are not coming from leaks
now CBS News has learned that the
Justice Department plans to announce
investigation to the leaking of
classified information how do you see
that playing out considering the public
drug drubbing rather that donald trump
is giving of jeff sessions well in a
sense it may be the way that this gets
settled down again it's amazing how
confused Republicans are who are allies
of Jeff Sessions who want the president
to do well our by this public kind of
situation that's that's emerged but yeah
Jeff Sessions has been looking into
leaks these are the illegal leaks these
are things of classified information
he's been doing this for a while he
mentioned it in his congressional
testimony they've actually already
charged somebody but this could be a way
if the Justice Department does something
publicly the president could take an
off-ramp and say well now they're taking
care of this thing everything's okay
it's back on track and I'll move on but
that's if he really wants his Attorney
General to stay and we're just not sure
whether that's the case or not John
thanks so much John Dickerson the book
Whistlestop my favorite story from
presidential campaign history is now
available in paperback and may we say
it's a very good read we've interviewed
John Dickerson about the book thank you
John